spindly creepy unsettling
skittering these are some of the words
and feelings that come to mind when you
think about the eight-legged arachnids
that plague
many of our nightmares it is no wonder
that spiders are used in many forms of
media
as elements of horror bent on
introducing fear into our hearts
video games are no exception especially
when it comes to the legend of zelda
one of the most recognizable monsters
plaguing the land of hyrule
is the unholy combination of a spider
with a human skull as its abdomen
called the sculptula the giant bone
spider looms above the ground
hanging from the branches of the trees
or a ceiling for hours on end
waiting silently for its prey to
unknowingly walk underneath its death
trap
and when the prey is in position it
swiftly and accurately swoops down to
entangle its next meal in a matter of
seconds with the sheer size of the
sculpture ranging from
1 to over 5 feet in diameter one finds
themselves
very thankful that they only exist
inside a video game
as they are absolutely large enough to
consume an unwitting human being that
just so happened to walk under the wrong
branch
the game that introduced these horrific
arachnids to the world was none other
than ocarina of time
which is a legendary zelda title well
known by fans for its darker undertones
see what i mean in the village of
kakariko which at one point was
inhabited solely by the mysterious chica
tribe
there stands a house that has long since
been abandoned
by its inhabitants or so the villagers
would like to believe
you see what crawls along the floors and
walls of that lonely house is neither
man nor
beast but the cursed family of
half-human half-sculptural amalgamations
for those familiar with the game you'll
recall that this family
is the reason that the gold sculptural
enemies exist their curse is somehow
bound to the existence of this
subspecies of sculptura
once all 100 of these golden spiders
have been killed throughout the land of
hyrule
and their tokens have been retrieved the
family's curse can be broken
but over the past two decades even
though there have been
countless theories covering why or how
the sculpture family became
cursed to begin with one that has seldom
been mentioned is who
exactly cursed them in this year's
halloween special
which you're currently watching i'm
going to cover all of it
so turn out your lights pay no attention
to the figure standing behind you
and follow me into the house of the
sculpture
as far as the family's origin is
concerned there are some who believe
that they are in fact
members of the sheikah clan along with
the original villagers who inhabited
kakariko
this theory is mainly built upon the
facts that they are in kakariko and they
possess the stone of agony which is
known to be the companion item to the
lens of truth
the former revealing secret grottos by
vibrating the nintendo 64
controller and the latter revealing
hidden areas false walls
and even invisible enemies at the cost
of magic power it is easy to assume the
two objects are related but i don't
necessarily believe this immediately
confirms the family's shika ties
in my opinion their human appearances
disprove any possible ties they might
have
after all the stone could have simply
been stolen by the greedy family
regardless of affiliations
their hair is red and their eyes are
shown to be blue in the 3ds remake of
the game
both features that contrast the
sheikah's iconic white hair and red
eyes their clothing and furniture also
completely lack
any shika symbolism and since their
house is largely in the same condition
as all the other surrounding buildings
plus or minus a few boarded up windows
i think this means that the family moved
into and visibly lived in the house
after kakarika was open to the public
therefore leaving no room for the house
to have been abandoned since the
original chica days
judging from their furniture's design
and their human appearances
they were most likely hylian settlers
that arrived once impa opened the
village to the public
just your average shady filthy rich
family
now as far as how they happen to get
themselves cursed the most obvious
answer is given to us by the old man in
ocarina of time
if you speak to him at night as adult
link inside the house at the bottom of
the stairs
he tells you of a fabulously rich family
in the village that became
cursed due to their greed an obvious
reference to the cursed
sculptura family there is no clear
reason to not believe his words as if
you speak to him while he's walking
around outside in the daytime his
information about the location of the
lens of truth is also correct
the bottom of the well the family's
reputation for riches goes beyond even
the walls of kakariko
if you speak to the zora salesman in the
zora's domain shop he will remark that
the zora armor's fine quality makes it
very expensive
and that only the very rich family of
kakarika village could afford to
purchase it but while it's one thing to
be known for your riches and achieve
fame throughout your successes it's a
completely different situation when you
mix in
the greed factor logically speaking the
only way someone would appear
immorally greedy is if they acted on it
in real life
we would call this stealing in this case
what makes the most sense to me is that
the rich family became
so rich and famous through their acts of
greed or rather
through thievery this doesn't really
matter much but the father of the family
was even
designed to look well kind of sleazy in
my opinion
but either way i think this family of
con artists
being used to making shady deals and
stealing their way to riches
made one deal that they soon came to
regret deeply
the father of the family once his human
form is regained
states that he will try to not get
cursed again meaning the transformations
were obviously not his intent
but rather an accident based on what he
was doing
but to explain this deal i have to jump
from ocarina of time to another
more mature and dark zelda title
twilight princess
in twilight princess there is a very
similar curse made to a very similar
individual in hyrule castle town named
giovanni
this man made a deal for more money and
was turned into money himself
solid gold actually his curse is also a
familiar one
link must find and destroy 100 imp pose
and jovani's curse will be broken
the pattern here is almost completely
identical except for instead of spiders
made out of gold being created because
of the curse
giovanni himself was made into gold two
parties making greedy deals and
receiving a terrifyingly twisted curse
because of it
the curses of the sculptura family and
the curse of giovanni are
so similar to one another that i happen
to believe they may have been created by
the same individual
as do many others however the individual
in question here is where opinions
differ amongst
theorists so what i am going to do in
this video is present to you
three different possibilities for the
one who placed the curses and if you
would
please let me know in the comments below
which one makes the most sense
to you the first possibility would be
taken from the words of a child in
hyrule castle town in twilight princess
who states that giovanni's soul was
taken by the imps
this is a reference to the imp pose that
each must be destroyed to free jovani's
soul
but if the implication here is that he
made his golden deal
with said pose as the zelda pediawiki
also states
this would have to be the same deal
brokered for the sculptura family of
ocarina of time in other words
pose or ghosts are the first possibility
who may have cursed the family after a
deal was made with them
the second possibility is the demon of
hatano village from breath of the wild
trapped within a statue this wicked
individual spends whatever time people
will give him
brokering deals to manipulate the life
forces of his
clients if this individual who calls
himself
a god that governs life and power is
really a demon or other supernatural
being
there's no reason to believe he couldn't
have been alive long long ago in the age
of ocarina of time
he admits that people normally ask him
for riches
and his cynical nature leads me to
believe that he may have promised riches
in gold
to the sculpture family and to jovani
but twisted their fulfillment into the
golden spiders and golden skin
for his own sick amusement the
counter-argument could be made that he
does not make
similar kinds of deals in breath of the
wild but it's clear to me that since
he's been sealed inside of a statue by
hylia herself
he may just be in a weakened state and
unable to perform the same kinds of
curses he used to
i mean i'd imagine that's why highly
asseeled him inside a statue in the
first
place the third and final possibility is
that the deal was made
with an unknown being this sounds like a
strange choice but hear me out
if poe's holding giovanni's curse means
that giovanni made a deal
with a po or pose then logically
speaking
the golden spiders that hold the
sculptural family's curse would mean
that the sculptural family
made a deal with golden spiders or maybe
just
one you see in their house there are
still a few portraits hanging on the far
side of the wall while most of them are
just pictures of creepy individuals or
landscapes
one picture in particular sticks out and
raises some questions
they appear to have a picture of a
golden sculpture hanging on their wall
one that looks slightly different than
the models that appear in game
if they began their transformations
immediately following their golden deal
they wouldn't have been able to hang
these pictures after the curse meaning
for some reason they already knew
about the golden sculptures what if
there is or was
one of these spiders in particular that
they attempted to make a deal with
for more gold like a spider deity of
some sort similar to the golden goose of
fairy tale
there is absolutely no evidence to
support this spider's existence other
than the similar pattern for giovanni
and the picture hanging on the wall but
you have to admit
it's definitely more than odd that it's
there
so which possibility is it was it a poe
a mysterious spider
the demon of hatano village or something
else entirely let me know what you think
in a comment below
also thank you so much for watching the
halloween special this year
and a huge thanks to everyone for
getting the channel to 100
000 subscribers i will be doing
something special to properly celebrate
this milestone so stay tuned for that
coming up
also enormous thanks as always to my
fantastic supporters
of which i have a new face to announce
say hello to merlin
who recently joined the ranks of my
personal heroes if you're interested in
earning my eternal gratitude and helping
the next video come to life
check out that join button below every
video or follow the links in the
description below to find out how
also be sure to drop a like if you
enjoyed this video to get it spread
around on youtube space
and make sure you're subscribed to stick
around for all the nintendo goodness to
come
also down in the description are links
to my social media pages so please feel
free to stop on by and say hi
that's all i've got for this one so i
hope you have a very spooky halloween
this is mass intended bandit signing out
peace
you